there's not a lot of information that
can't be found on the internet usually
via the search engine Google but who
exactly is behind the digital giant in
1998 Google was founded by larry page
and sergey brin just two years later it
had become the world's largest search
engine and remains so to this day it
sees a turnover of sixty billion dollars
a year and has a seventy percent market
share of online searches but the shine
is slowly starting to come off the
company's image das papers God knows why
he's observed the inexorable rise of
Google over the years not only is its
habit of collecting sensitive data a
cause of growing concern it also invests
in research projects that many might
consider dubious my google is prepared
to spend a lot more money on research
and development that other companies
would shy away from which they would see
as utopian and not actually viable this
pioneering spirit coupled with Google's
financial cloud makes it an incredible
innovative force as well as one that out
distances itself from traditional German
IT companies by far because of some
absolute up paint Google X is the name
of the company secret laboratory where
scientists work on ideas for tomorrow's
world Google glass and self-driving cars
are just the beginning with the mission
of providing internet access to rural
and remote areas for example it's placed
high altitude balloons in the
stratosphere to create an aerial
wireless network
it's even developed a contact lens for
diabetics that can measure glucose
levels if it's Devon hostess I
confidently expect that Google can and
will increase its profitability even
more with new products probably not with
all of them but it's no big deal for
Google if a few ideas don't pan out
maybe it's robots won't sell but the
cars will or the other way around but
experimentation is factored into its
business model Google is so financially
sound that it can afford quite a few
failures in coming years is Google
visionary or is it bent on world
domination as long as the jury is still
out on the world's leading search engine
Google will continue in its efforts to
shape the world in its image